j'ai pris
voyons là il ne devrait pas tarder à
arriver je crois que je vais faire un
excellent goûter où
les voilà casimir pouvons nous rend très
bien sûr que vous pouvez entrer mais
casimir n'est pas là puisque vous je
vous ai demandé de venir pour lui faire
une surprise à l'appel mauvaise humeur
tu pourrais au moins nous dire bonjour
les o na waie si vous voulez bonjour
julie bonjour là bonjour
françois nos jours les honneurs
comment très bien très bien nous avons
perdu assez de temps comme ça on
travaille au travail la ligne on
bouscule pau nous venons très gentiment
apporter tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
un délicieux goûter et une aura jj je
crois que les honneurs veut nous faire
comprendre qu'une façon pas très
délicate cerep que tats-unis on va
arriver d'une minute à l'autre
eh bien tu vois je lis lui il est moins
bête qu'il en a l'air facile alors
occupons nous de ce bts
et les dut sûr que que karim est un va
vraiment aimé ça évidemment ces gâteaux
et ses fruits ont l'air des messieurs
[Musique]
justement j'ai peur qu'il ne soit trop
bon
quoi et vous prétendez être ses amis
bravo et bien moi je pense que rien
n'est trop beau pour casimir léonore
l'honneur nos julie veut te faire
comprendre que ces cathos sont un petit
peu trop normaux pour casimir
de toute façon génère des cas près de la
voûte à pour arranger tout ça quoi mais
il n'en est pas question
pas de cap pas de moutarde sur ses
gâteaux et puis d'abord c'est moi qui
lui fait une surprise à les revoir
bientôt
au revoir
15h
[Musique]
ce renard est vraiment grandir nous a
même pas dit merci bonjour mes très
chers amis bonjour monsieur du snav il
paraît ces guerres entre et cela ne
m'étonne pas du tout quant aux casimir
et loi du jardin tout paraît bien triste
il me suis juste nommé casimir est dans
l'île aux enfants il est en ce moment
même en train de goûter chez lui avec
les honneurs
impossible les u moi même ce matin
s'embarquer pour une visite de
courtoisie chez son oncle archibald
le goûter surprise de léonard non je
crois que j'ai compris et je vais aller
lui dire deux mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien ce que je pensais léonard tu
nous a roulés
mais mon pauvre léonard s'est bien ta
faute aussi tu as mangé trois fois trop
je voudrais dormir
effectivement je crois que c'est ce qui
te reste est de mieux à faire et oui
mais je ne peux m'endormir que si on
chante une chanson donc je veux bien
faire ça pour toi aller
[Musique]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
beaucoup de douceur
[Musique]
je voudrais
me trilles
[Musique]
j'y vois les garçons
argent
françois
[Musique]
je leur ai mieux pas si je vais
et mieux pas si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela
ça
[Musique]
dans le kiosque que les poupées
ou les
ollier
couleur cerise
[Musique]
à
papillons passe
[Musique]
pas si sûr
j
utile
[Musique]
mais je n'en fais mieux pas si je t'aime
si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]